who do you think the strongest character
is
in the game and who is the strongest
character in the movie i think gary's
probably the strongest in the game right
you know i feel like he's the biggest
and strongest in the game but in the
movie
that's tough i mean it's sub-zero in the
movie i guess
raiden though lord raiden he's he's
pretty strong you know
yeah it's sort of untouchable yeah
that's a tough one man they've all got
the strengths and weaknesses that's the
thing about the mortal kombat universe
right you know
in the right hands anyone could be the
strongest
i completely agree uh this is not in the
movie but did you guys ever joke around
on set
and discuss what your character's
friendship would be
so what sort of things just tell me what
what do they look like the friendships
um give me an example uh like cooking
food
or like painting a picture or like i
think even ice skating
like i love but we definitely will now
yeah that's funny mine would be mine
would be netflix and chill
yeah um who do you think is the most
brutal fatality in the game
some of them are so messed up in the
game like it's it's
mental yeah the one one that we've
spoken about where it's like
kano kills and then dances with the dead
body yeah
like stabs stabs in the neck with a
broken bottle and then as they bleed out
he just dances with him
i mean that's messed up
uh this is actually a real question um i
think that people are gonna watch the
movie
i think people like to learn about stuff
that they don't know
so what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making
of mortal kombat i think that it's a
they really use minimal um green screen
and cgi
it was majority of what you see was
really created
and we were on real sets in real
costumes and
yeah it was like being in the video game
yeah look i can tell i mean you know i
could give you
we shot in australia we shot in adelaide
in
south australia and that was that was
amazing to be able to assemble this uh
international cast all the way
on the other side of the world down
under uh so that was that was a hell of
a lot of fun
um but uh yeah god in terms of
things that might really surprise you i
mean it may surprise you to learn that
i'm not a martial arts expert in real
life
yeah that's gonna shock a few people
[Laughter]
got it what uh listen i uh i appreciated
all the
the really good action scenes and like
what you guys put into making this movie
which is the day that when you were
filming you're like [ __ ] this is going
to break me oh i think
it was potentially uh our fight at the
end
um particularly once we like fall out of
that bathroom window and we're like
being i'm being like dragged on the
gravel by josh
i was like ouch and it was like 5 am
on sunday morning we'd gone shot all
saturday night
and it was raining and cold and i was
like yeah
this is and it was at the very end of
the very end of the shoot
in like december right before christmas
before we wrapped i was like this will
break
yeah i think for me it was the it's that
scene where i get my arcana where i have
to go on this big
angry rat where rage is fury is the
thing that unlocks his
is superpower right but you know in the
in the movie it goes for i don't know a
few minutes
but uh those few minutes took about 10
hours
it was it by the end of the day i felt
like i'd uh
i felt like i'd run a marathon with my
voice and
i i remember going over the end of that
day just collapsing into a heap
i got to stop there congrats on the
movie i hope it's a huge hit you guys
get to make another
thanksgiving